hey guys I'm Ryan right hey guys I'm
Andrew Andrew and I are gonna check out
from all-time movies top 5 worst movie
accent wait before we start take your
guess on which ones that some of them
are gonna be in here just one or two for
me Bruce Willis Armageddon I think he's
gonna be in there but that was pretty
bad accent he had in my opinion there
has to be a Liam Neeson movie in there
yeah I could see that he cannot I mean
he nearly Mason's interesting cuz he can
suck at accents but do a good
performance - you know yeah of course
let's let's find out let's find out what
they have to say hi I'm Jamie and these
are my five worst movie accents so like
that
number five Don Cheadle the oceans -
really this one is pretty funny but it's
also spread across a whole trilogy yeah
I think it mine oh great one two three
four the native New Yorker was going for
cockney here there so Pony that had gone
and blown a Becca Brit one by one like
dominoes Cheadle is rumored to have
requested the cockney character called
bash ATAR which makes the result even
more painful
watch out Dick Van Dyke so unless we
intend to do this job in Reno we're in
Barney Barney Rubble trouble no quite
cockney rhyming slang number four
Michael Caine on deadly ground or Cider
House Rules now we have a cockney actor
the one and only Michael Caine trying to
be Texan who cares we do these animals
stick his New England accent in The
Cider House Rules isn't much better
anyone nos go for it doubtless you will
let me know when you're gonna find a
more gratifying life Caine is an
absolute legend he should just stay away
from accents or give Don Cheadle some
tips on cockney rhyming slang number 3
Tom Cruise her far and away also from
New York Tom Cruise is playing a
nineteenth-century Irish immigrant
alongside his then wife Nicole Kidman
was actually Australian and also has a
pretty bad Irish accent
that's what for me farm boy you wouldn't
even be here Oh what if it weren't for
me miss hi
sounds like a leprechaun I keep
expecting to stop selling cereal they're
always after me lucky charms
how is Right Saxon to use next time oh
it's fine right I'm still not convinced
but he's not the only actor with a
terrible Irish accent yeah well I don't
number two Anne Hathaway
one day she probably wins for the most
annoying [ __ ] accent although born in
Brooklyn she's going for Yorkshire here
leads to be specific actually we have
several times so I think a crest net
birthday party called me Julie and stop
red right down the dark we can't she
just choose one bad accent and stick to
it no ricochet between [ __ ] and [ __ ]
accents sorry I'm not good at this it's
just fun a break go to bed with someone
I always end up either laughing or
weeping in between next time you take on
a beloved book character with a
different accent than your own get off
the couch and hire a professional number
1 Keanu Reeves Dracula I'm putting Keanu
was number 1 of this list because he's a
repeat offender with a nice
multinational portfolio of [ __ ]
accidental savage French southern and
last but not least English gent if I may
inquire what in fact happened to mr.
Renfield in Transylvania
why can't kiala just stick with being a
STONER or dodging bullets and before I
go here are a few others I just couldn't
leave out oh good you go son
you say the bunny back in the box
because me about Betty
the humans have played their hand well
do you think that the hawk Sheriff will
give everything back after I'm gone
there's no what tell me in the comments
don't forget to Like and subscribe
I remember when Robin Hood came out
[ __ ] Kevin Costner everyone was
saying he can't do a British accent you
hear it you're like there's like no
British accent another thing it was
pretty [ __ ] [ __ ] but you got to
admit that's one of the best cast that
movie it's a pretty good movie yeah he
came out of run Robin Hood men in tights
yeah run men in tights aloof yeah men in
tights was 94 I believe that was Mel
Brooks and then yeah I think the one we
just saw with Kevin Costner I believe
that was 91 I think that was three years
before that I could order 1992 ninety
one there's like oh yeah spider spoof in
spiders you're gonna joke about how what
was the main actor's name Carrie oh no
yeah where he was like even though he's
like I could do a British accent yeah
yeah don't you and one doesn't bother me
that much I was like I was okay with it
I agree if it never personally bothered
me and it never took me out of the film
once and I actually used one of my
favorite characters in the in the
trilogy even though I didn't really care
for the Ocean's Twelve I love 11 and 13
but he's one of my favorite characters
of in the in the group I agree that
personally never bothered me again more
the Bruce Willis one in Armageddon
bothers me way more than that one yeah
surprise that wasn't on the list yeah
and I even honorable mention those
interesting Michael King that's that's
the thing there are certain actors like
I said Liam Neeson and Michael Caine
he's another actor who can't really do
accents but they can still give a strong
performance when you look at this list
of accents you'll see actors who get so
focused on the accent they'll do a
shitty job and they're so focused on it
that they're not even really doing the
performance dude I can't believe they
bagged on Alfred are you kidding me
Bruce Wayne's Butler and how many Oscars
does he want I know he won for Hannah
and her sisters and by the way fun fact
he did not attend the Hannah and her
sister the Academy Award he was filming
of
wonderful film called jaws the revenge
oh really that's why he missed the
Academy Awards that year to accept his
Oscar he was filming jaws the revenge
and they say Cider House Rules as well
yeah Cider House Rules I think that was
1999 that came out yeah it's Michael
Caine
he never take even if his accent is a
little off he's such a good actor that
he never takes me out of it even you
know if his accents a little off here
and there I will say though even though
we're on the worst accents the best
accent I've ever heard personally
Leonardo DiCaprio and the Blood Diamond
that was amazing that was amazing South
African oh my he's so hard to do and I
was thinking the whole movie
I know this guy is from LA he is
completely South Africa's convincing me
what a brilliant performance it's
amazing it's funny how they show like an
honorable mention of him in gangs in New
York yeah when that was funny yeah I
mean it wasn't the greatest accent but I
remember like if you look at the Capra's
career there was gangs in New York catch
me if you can came out around the same
exact time same year and yeah it was the
same month to actually think something
like that yeah they're both two dozen to
I remember
so they both come out and then it was
like all right DiCaprio is not so pretty
boy anymore it's starting to become a
man aviator people were still like he's
getting there and then departed people
were like Mars [ __ ] one diamond
solidified it did he remember to they
couldn't nominate him like over both
yeah because they wanted to but they
couldn't he should've absolutely parted
is is actually my favorite performance I
I agree departed is my and again I know
I said the the action for for Blood
Diamond was my favorite but performance
- I completely departed was my favorite
one I loved how you know how greedy that
movie was and how in his performance and
oh so good oh the Tom Cruise of a
co-payment money I seen it's maybe a few
guns oh man I forgot how bad that was
like I saw it when I was a kid yeah now
we'll the kidnapped is now I'm like this
is a horrible no directed the film Ellen
Ron Howard no 92 Ron Howard by the way I
remember when I saw this as like five or
six years old the first thing that stuck
out to me was Tom Cruise is awful Irish
accent you came back from the dead to
tell me I'm on
Oh God like dude it sounds like the most
area - they're after my potatoes oh yeah
what that guy said I was like is he
gonna sell me some cereal soon because
ya waiting for it and Nicole came in
pretty bad - yeah it's like this is the
Eyes Wide Shut prequel yeah Cameron Diaz
in gangs in New York no that's an
exception for me because I'm light so he
does a good job in it you know like yeah
she's not someone who is the most
seriously taken actress and then
Scorsese puts her in this and she does a
great job even though the action that's
not good the performance is still
absolutely I completely agree if if the
accent is and always you know as
obviously I prefer you know an authentic
good accent but you know if the
performance is very good I agree it
doesn't take me too much out of the film
there's some bad accident I feel like
taking should have gotten mentioned to
be on yeah that was that was pretty bad
that's a fun movie all it's great Liam
Neeson is awesome in it I love that
bison at one point when he's pretending
to be a French officer who's actually an
American with an Irish accent okay got a
little convoluted there it's not the
greatest [ __ ] accent I'm surprised
that wasn't on the list or at least an
honorable mention and Anne Hathaway and
at the way it's the two ones that he
chose number two and one and I have to
ain't Keanu Reeves and both actors
that's weird
Anne Hathaway has a lot more respect for
my critics but amongst audiences she
seems to be hated oh yeah remember would
you remember the reaction when she was
cast as Catwoman
oh yeah Pio piss and I mean like I'm not
gonna lie when it happened it was like
you know what Christopher Nolan picked
Heath Ledger I trust him I'm gonna see
how this I'm gonna see the film if I
personally don't like it afterwards I'll
let it be known but I trust this guy in
his decisions and I thought she even
though I don't personally like that film
The Dark Knight Rises and I'm the
biggest die hardest Batman fan I
personally thought she did a great job
and she was a good cattleman and I
thought I thought she did great but you
know that was very interesting I didn't
see the movie they mentioned here I
didn't see that even I heard it was
pretty bad yeah I never saw but the
accident I mean as we were watching and
I thought yeah yeah I guess not a great
accent but Keanu Reeves Oh God he sucks
that accent oh god yeah like the first
movie I saw when an accent was devil's
advocate and I
I know that movie I was like dude go
back to surfer accent yeah go back to
surfer accent because he had the surfer
accent with a slight southern touch oh
yeah I know I was like dude grab the
surfboard already they even show a
moment of his French accent but I think
that was for my comedy so I don't really
do I'm not bothered by that because it's
a comedy I find that more funny than bad
but no I mean Keanu Reeves is he's one
of those actors who has of recent
started getting better after the matrix
there's a couple of big movies whatever
but didn't do well but he was started
doing like indie flix and I think he
became a better actor through there and
then his last big film was John wick and
he was great and John like so much fun
that was like this is not the Keanu
Reeves ever yeah this is a great movie
which is such a pleasant surprise
he was so good yeah Wow this is like
this Keanu Reeves no more of this matrix
is like my favorite movie that my
favorite Keanu Reeves performance is
probably John wick so he's evolved me
personally I the John wick one it's
never a good Point Break I love that
movie so much it's such a such I grew up
with that movie it's Kathryn Bigelow she
was married to James Cameron's I think
it was in second life and I think James
Cameron is actually executive producer
for that film I loved Point Break that
accent was perfect for you Keanu Reeves
I can pack him on that one
yeah man devil sailor him in yeah and
him and Patrick Swayze a dude they were
awesome but anyway yeah that's a fun
list if when you do the channel you can
subscribe to the real rejects you can
follow Andrew on Twitter at that name he
has a Gore 7-eleven I'm very good at
remembering that and you can follow me
on Facebook Instagram Twitter vine and
periscope because if we get more
followers we can make even more product
placement
yah-ha I'll rub a the pain how do I get
a shout-out exactly do i message you are
posted well you're gonna get one ring
now my friend because you have asked on
the shout out page that's that simple
yaha i'll robe a the pain you know
that's actually a kind of a sex maneuver
yeah I'm actually impressed with how how
you got that name down so perfectly on
the first try that was impressive man
you read a lot of names on YouTube yeah
and I could be completely wrong but yah
ha or obey the pain that's the type of
position where like I can't say anything
about you because of your profession but
I can talk about you yah from whatever I
want to say what that is and riyo just
so you know is when a man stands upside
down and then the woman urinates on his
face while she pulls his penis causing
the pain sounds like a scene from Not
Another Teen Movie oh wait now if she
corrected that a member he crapped on
her chest it wasn't peed in my bed oh
yeah but the yah hah I'll Roby the pain
too is when you crap on their face oh
that sounds interesting yeah you know
let's go for you're not a kid let me
confirm this real fast you're totally a
kid listen I didn't mean any of that
but in the future if you want to piss
her crap on a girl's face you do it
don't let your parents manipulate you
into not doing what you want to do i
crap on girls now I don't do that that's
disgusting you're a pervert